what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i am going to be reacting to
dr dre um he is ordered to pay his
ex-wife nicole young
3.5 million a year in spousal support so
this is just like a yahoo article
i found so i'm gonna watch the video and
then tell you
and read the article and then tell you
my thoughts
[Music]
okay nicole young will be receiving a
substantial amount of money
from dr dre amid their divorce
according to reports the music mogul
will pay his ex-wife
almost 300 000 per month in spousal
support accounting more than
3.5 million a year
well it's a good chunk of change for
most people the sum is much less than
she requested in september
of 2020 oh my god she asked for 2
million a month
the rapper will also cover the expenses
of their malibu
and pacific palestine
homes will pay for young's health
insurance
[Music]
if she remarries or entered a new
domestic mark a partnership the
agreement will end
oh my god i bet he will literally be
praying like trying to set her up with
all his friends
[Music]
praying that [ __ ] moves on oh my god
sorry i didn't mean to call her a [ __ ]
i don't know her um okay
let's see a judge ordered the music
mogul to pay
300 000 a month in spousal support
according to reports that's more than
3.5 million a year well it's a good
chunk of change for most people okay so
basically he has a lot
more money um he's a billionaire right
young filed for a divorce um oh so she
left him
in june of 2020 after 24 years of
marriage and the process has been
anything but amicable
she accused the producer of emotional
and physical abuse
which he has strongly denied see no one
in the manosphere
has talked about this with the physical
abuse
possibly i don't know dr dre was
declared legally single by a judge
as his attorney powerhouse laura
wasswasser
filed a motion for what does
beefurication
mean um she argued young's false
allegations of domestic
violence demonstr demonstrate their
union is
beyond repair um their voice divorce is
yet to be finalized i don't know where i
heard it but i heard
that he was
like cheating on her and stuff see this
is the hard part
for me this is the hard part where i
actually
probably have a little bit different of
an opinion in the manosphere clearly
that's a lot of money
um very clearly it's not
logical for him to have to pay her
in perpetu perpetuity oh my god i can't
talk
basically have to pay her until she dies
or remarries
um 300 000 a month like that's clearly
insane
however
i think there should be legal
protections for men and women so like
genuinely
i don't if a girl marries a guy at 20
right
builds helps him um i don't want to say
builds him up because clearly like
men build themselves up but like is
there for him
for 20-plus years and then when she gets
old he decides to like
cheat on her all the time treat her a
certain way um
because you know now he's got more
options or whatever
um so that's where i have a hard time
is i do think that women should have
some sort of legal protection
if a man like basically
is takes her youth and then
all of a sudden just bounces but at the
same time
there's no legal protection for men when
a woman cheats or a woman
you know ends the marriage or does
something
terrible so that's just like where my
mind is at but my
problem is i can't think of a solution
that would make sense for either parties
so part of me thinks that maybe at the
end of the day
the government should just like not be
involved in marriage at all
but then it's like the equivalent of
just living with someone which doesn't
seem as serious
as marriage because you can leave at any
time so part of me thinks maybe there
should be some legal binding
um
because i think it would just be a
little bit too easy to like end
relationships and you'd see an
increase in like short-term as opposed
to long-term relationships but
i don't know clearly this isn't working
so
i don't know this is just my like first
thoughts but i'd really like to have a
conversation in the comments section
about what you guys think because
genuinely i'm just curious
um is there a way we could legally
protect women and
men or it should we just get the
government out of marriage let me know
in the comments don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell that way you're gonna be notified
of my daily videos okay guys i'll talk
to you guys next